[music playing]
RICHARD DOLAN: August 19, 1952,
the Scout leader, this man
named Sonny DesVergers.
He sees unusual activity
in this forested area.
He stops the cars and says
to the boys, wait here.
So he had three Scouts with
them, from ages 10 to 12--
Bobby Ruffing, David
Rowan, and Chuck Stevens.
He gets a machete
and a flashlight,
and he goes into these woods.
He says at a certain point
he's under a dark circle
with a light on it, and
he hears a hatch opening.
And then a red flash
of light comes out
and there's this red mist, he
said, that kind of envelops
him.
And then he blacked
out at that point.
The boys can't see
what's happening to him.
They run out and
try to get help,
eventually getting
law enforcement
to come and take a look.
But DesVergers, apparently,
was out for quite some time,
and then comes to and he's
got these burns on his body
and has this story.
And that's when
people wondered, well,
do we believe this guy or not?
DR. JACQUES VALLEE: A
member of the Air Force
was very skeptical of landings.
If it didn't fly and it
was seen on the ground,
they suspected a
psychological case or a hoax.
RICHARD DOLAN:
Captain Edward Ruppelt
went down physically to
investigate this case,
spoke to DesVergers, wasn't
impressed by DesVergers at all,
but admitted that he was baffled
by the nature of this evidence.
He didn't know
what to make of it.
DR. JACQUES VALLEE: They did
do the tests of the traces
around the place where
the object had been,
and they found that
the top of the plants
was not affected, that
the routes had been
exposed to high temperature.
And that was an
indication that there
was some physical effect
that was not understood
that took place there.
RICHARD DOLAN: In fact, they
took the grass samples to a lab
to try to recreate the
effect that was done to them,
and it required something
like 300 degrees
to have been applied,
and that seems
completely beyond the
capability of Sonny DesVergers
to have done that.
DR. JACQUES VALLEE: The Air
Force concluded that it was
a hoax or it was psychological.
In retrospect, I think Ruppelt
was impressed with the fact
that there were physical effects
that had not been explained.